I'm here with with a friend and a mentor
and a living legend give me one more
good adjective for you who are you
talking about
I'm talking about this guy right across
me we're pretty much dressed the same I
feel good about this it's real of a
lifetime we did this once that was the
thrill of a lifetime the first time and
now it's less than a year later well
surely I would I can only imagine what
it must be like to sit with legend so
what I want to start with you this time
because we did a lot of personal stuff
last time it's sort of the state of the
media because it seems to be we're in a
strange time with the media where
there's the mainstream media that nobody
seems to trust and now there's the
online media which is exploding and it
seems that nobody knows who to trust
anymore how do you decide who you trust
well my trust comes from experience
which is a great way to do it so I trust
a trust in the main the CBS's the NB C's
the ABCs I trust CNN I worked at CNN for
25 years I don't buy these stories of
plots at networks or I don't trust Fox I
don't trust them MSNBC I don't regard
them as really news networks but they're
more preaching to choir network yeah so
you think there's a distinct difference
between the cable news guys and and the
traditional now obsolete CNN does try to
report fairly CNN is a difficult
position because there's so much today
is so box tough mm-hmm so they've got
Fox on the right and MSNBC on the left
and CNN straddles it sort of carrying a
lot of documented I don't know where
they are
yeah you know what I respect them yeah
the main still trust the mainstream
maybe I think though that a lot like tea
parties and the like have made you try
to distrust the mainstream media but I
have never seen in I've been in the
business 58 years yeah telling us the
people come over to me they tell me CNN
hates Israel or just kidding I have
never been in a meeting where someone
said let's go get somebody right let's
angle the story this way let's twist
I have never seen this so at the end of
the day is it really just about what
people will watch more than an agenda
because that's what I see all the time
people comment especially online you get
a lot of the conspiracy people and they
say oh this one has this agenda or this
one's owned by this one or that but to
me it always comes down to what people
will watch and click so if there's a
riot they're gonna cover a riot more
than they would be inclined to cover a
rally for peace right because it's it's
just what people will turn on well news
is well first personally I never had an
agenda
I never went on the air to hurt someone
or to boost someone I just try to ask
good questions and listen to you're not
boosting me right now no I
well you're interviewing me oh so I knew
if we got--we our date I've never I
never had an agenda I trust I trust them
you know I said I know print maybe is in
trouble
I trust the New York Times I think it's
the greatest newspaper I've ever read
and every day gets better and I've never
seen a paper that introduces me and
opens up doors to me better than the New
York Times and The New York Times
frankly and some cases The Washington
Post the LA Times but mainly the New
York eyes television networks follow the
New York Times it's based a lot of what
they cover yeah is what the New York
Times is showing them what to cover sure
great respect for the New York Times the
cable news part of it this
hyper-partisan thing that we see all the
time where Fox is obviously to the right
some people say they're not even to the
right they're just a sort of offshoot of
the Republican Party MSNBC is giving you
democrat talking points CNN as you said
somewhere in between what do you make of
this idea that we're it's constantly -
people screaming at each other well it's
not my kind of broadcasting yeah I the
problem with those shows to me I don't
learn anything yeah you know to me when
I watch a show I want to know more than
I knew before I watch the show in these
screaming shows I see screaming but I
don't know more I don't see many good
interviewers yeah I see the host on if
you turn on a TV show on a regular basis
and the host is on more than the guests
yeah that's a bad show yeah in my face
and yet people seem to want screaming
what's dead like you mentioned if
there's a riot in the streets and a
peaceful protest you're gonna cover the
riot
for example I'll tell you a newscast
that wouldn't do well good evening
ladies and gentlemen
every school in America today
experienced no problems there were no
guns at any school today and there were
no hit-and-run accidents in major cities
yeah you're tuning off you're not gonna
watch this right so news is that which
is not the ordinary
yeah so then wrapping up this topic how
do you feel about being you're sort of
you obviously came from the mainstream
and what you do now you're still talking
to mainstream people but it's in the
digital space how do you like being in
this sort of next to me I'm doing what
I've always done I since 1957 when I
broke in I've asked questions listened
to answers try to follow up I'm being
distributed differently
I was distributed first on a local
station yeah then I had a national radio
show
then satellites and then there was CNN
it was worldwide and now now the
Internet but I'm doing the same thing
there's this what we're doing now yeah
could have been a radio show in 1935
yeah one day we're gonna be doing this
on snapchat that'll be it maybe 2
seconds long so I want to talk about
what everyone's talking about right now
which is race in America so obviously
there was this shooting in Charleston I
just heard just on the way here now that
Lindsey Graham and Tim Scott both
senators from South Carolina are calling
for the Confederate flag to be taken
down
no they woke up they finally woke up I
saw your tweet about it I mean they
finally find a Confederate flag is
treason yeah it is it is a sign of an
era that is the worst mark in the
history of this country slavery is the
black mark no pun intended on the
American landscape and the what would
you say the people that say well this is
southern pride this is sight sorry it's
our hair I would say it's baloney yeah
your southern pride your heritage is
slavery you like that heritage right
that's the good old days the good old
days was depression and no that wasn't
the good old days it was a bad old days
and when you put that up your black
citizens and they vote in your state
South Carolina might have more black
voters than white voters and you do that
as the symbol that's and now these two
senators are saying well we ought to
take it down
come on yeah they knew it was wrong
forty years ago yeah and isn't an
interesting piece with Tim Scott
particularly who's an african-american
senator Republican from the south I
believe the only one that he took him
even this long so that just shows you
how this stuff is so ingrained right
black Republican senators I have
interviewed many of a black congressman
enough Republican blanks you are
Republican amazed me they come to their
rationale like gay Republican yeah how
they come to their rationale when they
see how the main party votes yeah well
to me with with the gays it always seems
to me it seems so sad that if you were a
gay person that you would have to vote
Democratic because you feel that you
have to vote on this one issue which
marriage should be such a small piece of
what you would actually it should be but
where the Clintons dip into the gut
feeling is all the Tip O'Neill said all
politics is local
and when something hits your gut if you
if you're a black American you could say
which party I stood up them all for me
yeah the blacks always were Republicans
until the party turned against them and
the Democrat you know the Democrats to
the south right Southern Strategy and
all that kind of thing we're terrible
yeah so what do you make of the the
state of race in America and I'm so
you've interviewed everybody for as long
as we've had a black president do you
think did you think you think we're we
what we've come a long way yeah in fact
the you can disagree with Obama I've
disagreed with him you but the tenda
temper of the disagreement is
particularly distressful it's racist a
lot of it is groomed in racism yeah when
Mitch McConnell said we were out to beat
him the first day he took office
that's a terrible thing to say as an
American right that was a terrible thing
just
hey why would you say them right it's
bad for the nation regardless rush
limbaugh I hope he fails that's a good
American I hope you fail yeah
may the country fall down super ratings
what I've served it to you that is
that's absurd yeah so removing Obama
from the equation where do you think the
general state of racism is because it
seems it seems that a lot of people
think it's worse than ever
I don't think it's a systemic as ever
but we have major problem in some senses
it's great I mean we've made all
tremendous advances I mean blacks in
position of power blacks should key
blacks in I mean that ahead of the
Hayden Planetarium is black the one of
the richest Americans is black clearly
the strides have been great their
four-star generals you know come on
mm-hmm you got to admit we like that a
black president yeah yeah but then on
the other hand there's still that
insidious part but still it's a minority
but it's a dangerous minority that would
go shoot up a church yeah so speaking of
those guys what do you make so now
everybody there seems to be this big
debate was this a hate crime or a
terrorist attack and a lot of people are
saying well if if a Muslim had done this
of course we all would have said this
was a terrorist act but because this is
a white guy we're not saying a terrorist
attack it seems obvious to me this is a
hate crime and an act of terror he was
trying to terrorize these people well I
don't I call it hate crime terrorist
attacks for me is when a nation or a
body of people attack civilians when
civilians bear the brunt of it right so
as so as a lone wolf if I if I do a
suicide thing and go into the
neighborhood and blow up people who
aren't in the military if you're
fighting the military and it's a war
that's not terrorism so this is both
terrorism it is a terrorism of sorts but
it's first a hate crime yeah because I
hates black city wasn't shot up yeah so
where do we go from here
for the for the national discussion well
first we should be discussing this we
should be educating more people should
be discuss it's not on the second tier
it should be on one of it should be a
top tier it should be discussed a lot
mm-hmm
it should be discussed a lot in the
places where it should
discussed at tea party meetings and at
meetings in the south it should be
discussed Sunday mornings at 11 o'clock
yeah and which we know it will be for a
couple of weeks and then it sort of
disappears and unfortunately with the
with the crop of candidates we have
coming in 2016 actually ben Carson is
the only African American on either side
so it's probably not going to be brought
up that much yeah well it should be
brought I should be that's just because
you're you're white you can discuss it
yeah no I know it of course the white
person did the crime thing I wanted to
talk to you about the big thing this
week and that I've been hearing about a
lot lately is free speech and political
correctness so I don't know if you saw
this Jerry Seinfeld no just don't
belittle campuses don't go to college
campuses there too PC everything's
racist or homophobic or agreed with that
so Bill Maher's been talking about even
Larry the Cable Guy so when you have
Bill Maher Seinfeld Chris Rock Larry the
Cable Guy although our campus is that
way because I I have a sense that they
are that that unfortunately we're
teaching young people that anything that
you say that is sort of out of the the
mainstream think is automatically evil
it's automatically racing totally
totally that shouldn't be I'm funny I
love funny people Lenny Bruce was a
great friend of mine George Carlin yeah
these guys ran against the grain and
healthy comedy a lot of it hits home but
it's true it's come on
yeah and college campuses is where
irreverence should take place yeah why
would a college campus be a place where
you have to be politically correct I
would think of college campus would be
the opposite well it's supposed to be
the opposite right but somehow they they
go there and they somehow learn that
anyone who says so if you say anything
that might sound slightly against women
that automatically you hate all women or
if you believe in an economic policy
that maybe isn't isn't seen as
redistributing the way that they want
then you're then you're racist there's
just this stream Oh Jill Mar would not
be popular on campuses well that's the
irony
you know Berkeley remember Berkeley
didn't want him to the kids at Berkeley
didn't want him to speak and then and
then he did
but there was a petition portion of a
port yeah portion of and then of course
they did allow him to speak and Seinfeld
was Seinfeld wouldn't be allowed to
speak at a college yeah I can't I don't
buy that I mean he says it but right mom
well the idea of Seinfeld who of course
is little knowledge would most
politically correct comedian of all time
do you know is how many times have you
interviewed him I'm sure
yeah and do you know any of his
political beliefs and I was in a movie
with him the terrific the the Beeman
yeah Harry B King was a B I've had more
kids you know me from that than anything
else I don't know what his part but
that's fine yeah but doesn't that show
you how how silly the atmosphere is if a
guy that you don't know their political
beliefs a why won't Seinfeld work with
campus if that's what they want well he
said that he based it around this silly
gauge oak that he made about a French
King swiping an iPhone with a limp wrist
and he said oh people are saying that
that's that's homophobic and you know of
course that's not homophobic it's just a
silly joke it would take a you would
need a history I think that's what
people need to learn you would need a
history of saying something against a
certain group of people there actually
be bigoted or racist Rickles is
hysterical in these but but you take no
prisoners yeah great comedian takes no
prisoners
yeah you think we're a guy like Rickles
could make it today he's funny
and give it to me if you're funny you're
funny
you know Brooks is the funniest man I've
known funniest man I've ever seen and
Mel Brooks has it down he'll Brooks has
the philosophy of humor he has put the
best ready I'll give you the Mel Brooks
philosophy it applies to all cases at
all times if you fall down a manhole
it's funny if I cut my finger
it's tragic so let's talk a little bit
about the the election I'm very excited
because this is just it's a lot of
hanging meat for a comedian you know I
mean these are just softballs there and
so Donald Trump let's start with Donald
Trump Donald what do you make of this is
this real is this Donald as an old
friend of mine I tell they're two sides
to Donald he's a he's a good person
he's uh he's a great father he is a very
successful businessman and if you were
in trouble you could go to him Donald
has a good heart
Donald has an incredible ego and Donald
you like Donald because there's no cut
off from brain to mouth yes an interview
he's a piece of cake yeah you want him
yeah so he'll be refreshing he will tell
you exactly what he however demented
some of it would take exact what he
thinks about his fellow Republicans yeah
if I were a Republican candidate now I
would not look forward to this because
he will get attention he'll get so a
percentage of the polls he'll get on the
debates and it is and then all hell
could break loose right I mean to me I
think you're totally right he's walk out
he's gonna be wrapping these opponents
he's already wrapped Jeb Bush terribly
good he's gonna take them on yeah as he
called George Bush the worst president
till Obama came in to be the worst for
certai for his horse his two ties for
the worst president our Republican and a
Democrat yeah there you go but he's I
think he's delightful you know I mean
you look at him as uh so you're
separating the he's not gonna resident
so do you but do you think he's do is
this real is he do you think he's really
running for president cuz I have a sense
that this is sort of you know this is
brand and ego and then sometime around
October after a couple debates where I
think he's gonna do well he'll say I did
it and now now well there's that side
that says Donald could not stand going
into a primary and losing yeah because
that ego that couldn't take a defeat
yeah my old friend Howard Cosell the
late Howard Cosell a strong liberal all
of a said he's gonna run for the Senate
in New York and he but he never was
gonna run because he couldn't take the
fact that he would be voted down yeah so
maybe you're right maybe Donald will
campaign a little and get out before the
first vote saying I've made my voice
clear and I now endorse
such-and-such all right well we but I
don't think he wants to face an election
yeah but I like Donald Trump so what do
you make of the rest of the Republicans
because there's a ton of them it's
actually you know people mock the
Republican Party for not being
an open party and all that so it's an
open point actually now you know there
there is a woman there is a black guy
there's a Hispanic guy I mean there's a
lot of white guys but it they have
broadened it I'm not enamored with any
of these guys but they've done so there
are no moderate Republicans anymore they
used to be a great crew of moderate
Republicans there are no moderate
Republicans and as very few moderate
Democrats yeah Democrats uh swinging
Elizabeth Warren seems to be the the
heart of the Democratic Party and
Hillary is moving more toward his wife
so we have no centrist and when there
are no centrist that's a danger in a
republic mm-hmm because the Republic
needs compromise it needs centrist
Hillary was a centrist senator she was a
very good in fact Lindsey Graham told me
once he would be very comfortable if
Hillary Clinton ran for national office
because she could work with her right
she was in the Senate she knew how to
give and take and she could give up this
to get that that was that's very
important you have to do that yeah at
which we don't do anymore right they as
you said what McConnell said right when
Obama got a letter never gonna be defeat
him at every turn
so we have that kind of hate and that
does leave it on when I was a kid first
I could name every senator I can't do
that I won't make you do it now no you
don't I won't I wouldn't be able to do
it number two I knew that that certain
very Goldwater when John Kennedy were
friends Republicans the Democrats went
out yeah and had dinner together a
conservative Mormon and a democratic
liberal Ted Kennedy yeah D spoke at his
funeral they this is what America was
that's so is this just another thing
danger about it now is because of
Congress they come in on Tuesday and
leave on Friday because they're
constantly running for reelection on
this two-year thing they don't live in
Washington anymore they take a room in
Washington they run back home to Cantor
do things that are not there Friday
Saturday Sunday Monday yeah
so then is money is money in politics
only is that what every word everything
else is that were Supreme Court decision
yeah of all time was
SATA corporation is a person yeah and
that you can give any kind of money to
any kind of thing in us as freedom of
speech yeah that that decision was
horrendous
I think so it made a lot of horrendous
decisions they're making a bunch of
decisions now which way do you think
they're gonna go on gay marriage they
could be people are saying it could be
as early as this week I think Justice
Kennedy will swing that way I think he's
always went that way I've spent some
time with him
mm-hmm and I I would say it's five four
they'll swing that maybe even six three
yeah nobody wants to be on the wrong
side of history on know they know it's
happening anyway right and on health
care too yeah if you if they if they
throw out this any major portion of self
care thing get thirteen million people
are on it yeah you know health care as a
fact
and while you can look back and go what
for the concept you know come on
yeah we're the only industrialized
nation in the world until Obama had this
it didn't have a health care plan and
health is a right I think it's a right
so jumping back to the to the money in
politics I would be wrong if we if we
didn't mention Bernie Sanders and all
this hello you love Bernie okay so can a
seventy something year old Brooklyn Jew
socialist self-proclaimed socialist can
he actually affect this election I think
I think he can nudge it nudge it but not
effective no no no because he's got a
he'll make a nice impact and people you
know he's I love Bernie and Bernie will
it will have his say and he'll be an
excellent debater mm-hmm but Hillary's
going hello he's gonna get the
nomination and Bernie will campaign for
it and so will Elizabeth Warren and yeah
the Democrats will come behind Hillary
the Republicans will come by I know
whether the nominee is why she's I mean
are we really gonna have a Clinton Bush
is that if you had to get know people
make like that's bad I think that would
be a good race i but didn't this way we
have well I like Jeb Bush Jeb Bush is
very intelligent I've known him a long
time yeah Hillary and Bush Hillary and
Jeb I hope would be a clean discussion
of the issues fair discussion
interesting yes I would look forward to
that
yeah do you think that would be a battle
of ideas though to me what I want to see
is a battle of ideas I want to see
something like Rand Paul verse Barney
where it's really two people one a
libertarian the other one a socialist
who really have ideas and really let's
have an actual engagement of ideas
versus hip you know Jeb and Hillary we
know what it is we know Erika never
never accept Rand Paul versus Bernie
Sanders that would be an independent
would move in and win that I knew you'd
give me one piece of wisdom here listen
did I pay attention to it we got it all
right well thank you Larry King a
pleasure is great to be here on the
Rubin report